and joining us now former prosecutor
congressman fox news contributor trey
Gowdy you know I just have a problem
maybe I'm a little old-fashioned you
don't let anarchists take over cities
and the congressman or I guess that's an
insult that this point in your life
fellow colleague at Fox
if you don't stop it it's gonna get
worse and the governor won't that won't
do a thing and the mayor is basically
aiding and abetting in all of this
president offers every day when you're
ready I will help you whatever help you
need New York whatever help you need
Illinois whatever help you need no we
don't need any help so this doesn't end
well as I see it
well shall refresh my recollection I
think that the police in Seattle
actually retreated they surrendered
right they they abandoned the priests
the the police precinct so if these
protesters are really peaceful I don't
know why the police felt that they were
in danger or fear for their safety and
had to retreat the way I look at the
world saw there are mostly good cops and
a few bad there may be many peaceful
protesters but a few bad I think we're
better off in society if we
individualize it if you're gonna destroy
other people's property and break laws
then you should be arrested and I don't
care what Park you're in I don't care
what city you're in if you're a bad cop
you should be prosecuted if you're a bad
protester that breaks the law you should
be prosecuted also okay I don't think
it's hard to do now constitutionally
even the AG AG bar admits that the
president has the right the authority
constitutionally to go in and do it but
it's really the job of the governor it's
really the job of the mayor now if it
gets to a point where it's untenable the
president will have no other choice I
don't see that we're there when that
moment happens I assume it will be
transparent and obvious but why would
they allow this to happen what about the
business owners what about the home
owners that see their whole lives
upended where's their freedom and
protection Shawna baffles me I'm from a
state where were the two
priorities or education and public
safety and I just assume that's true
everywhere people want to be safe and
they want their kids to be adequately
educated most crime is state and local
the feds don't get involved in in ninety
nine percent of crime
so I think the president should use
federal power only if interstate
commerce is impacted only for the
ability to travel from state to state as
impact it otherwise this of Washington
problem they can fix it alright trey
gowdy thanks for that report we
appreciate it